deauville leur rend hommage à l'un des
grands acteurs américain al pacino est
arrivé au festival aujourd'hui nicole
cornu langlois et jean louis normandin
ont rencontré celui qui a fait ses
classes à l'actor studio de new york et
qui s'est révélé notamment dans un après
midi de chien ou encore le parent un
régal pour les photographes
al pacino joue avec infiniment de talent
et de cordialité la solitude de l'acteur
face à la foule et puis face à la presse
tout heureux que le festival lui
consacre un hommage visiblement ému il
évoque son métier qu'il considère comme
un instrument de musique centre et cette
fois on joue choix il faut toujours agir
et parfois on joue trop fort un pas
assez fort mais quand les acteurs jouent
ensemble comme les musiciens alors
presque on parvient est une sorte
d'harmonie et on joue la partition le
texte et le texte scellé
conséquence
chacun
la tête rentraient alors sur ma boîte et
l'autre chose intéressante c'est qu'un
acteur est une sorte d'athlètes de
l'émotion vivez avec vos émotions sont
toujours intenses et cossu et parfois
d'y jouer tellement que vous devez
utiliser à fond vos émotions pour être
le personnage
à force que lens est en contact avec
quelque chose de mystérieux vous êtes
sur le fil du rasoir
c est vrai que vous avez décidé d'être
acteur après avoir vu au théâtre la
mouette de tchekhov
je regardais cette pièce de tchekhov
j'avais 14 ans dans un immense 3
millions n'avaient rien changé ma vie et
m'a dit je voyais comme un signe sans
essai la victoire est belle et
maintenant quel est votre rêve le plus
fort sans trouver quelque chose qui me
réjouissent mecs qui me procure de
l'énergie me donne une
c'est ce que je recherche un soleil
aussi avoir des perso j'ai la chance
d'être dans cette situation je peux être
là tous les jours m
alors prochainement de nouvelles pages
s'ajouteront livre de sa vie
il vient de réaliser l'adaptation de
chinese koffi 2 ira lewis encore le
théâtre liés au cinéma